The Joe Rogan Experience what a crazy
thing that somehow or another we've been
disconnected from it not just as
disconnected but gotten to the point
where it's a schedule one drug
yeah schedule one drug right that's
crazy it's one of the great confusions
when you're when you're high on
mushrooms and you think okay you're in
jail yeah this is insane they don't want
us to feel like this oh my God they
should do it that's what's missing it's
not that our leaders are different than
us they are us but they're just humans
they're put in a bad position when
people get put in a position where they
could tell a bunch of people how to live
their lives and what to do and where
their families can live and what they
can say and what they can't say and you
jail dissidents and yeah that's just
what people do it's what people do when
they get power yeah they just [ __ ] it up
almost every time sure that's what this
country is supposed to be a remedy of
right that's what the this exercise in
self-government this experiment
this is the first one of them that we're
we're really aware of where people
branched off and created a country like
this
well
I'm reading this book about the
Revolutionary War is it wild it's so
good and I feel so dumb for not studying
it more because you'll feel better like
you know like if you
are one of the many people freaked out
by America right now like God the people
here are insane it's gone insane
they're always like that they were like
from the beginnings of the Revolutionary
War that colonists were like
these are like hardcore
people who a lot of them are
trying to start a Utopia
they're you know hyper religious some of
them are like the [ __ ] Taliban you
know they're they're burning I told you
they would burn Quakers
so like if you were a Quaker who and
you're already like uh running away
because different religions used to be
illegal think about that there if you
have the wrong religion if you wouldn't
say if you wouldn't confess that you
thought you know God was the only God or
whatever they could legally just set you
on fire
did you ever see all the things that
happened to the people that signed the
Declaration of Independence no what
happened you could find that they they
I'll I'll pull it up because I read it
in passing today and I thought it'd be
uh good to bring up and learn on the
spot
plus I was too lazy to read the article
wait was it a curse or something no no
no not a curse just they were they were
[ __ ] hunted down
a bunch of [ __ ] happened to him isn't
that correct
I'm gonna find a good place to get the
info that should be the first thing I
see it says five of them were chased
down by the Brit British wow and now I
can't really read this so I'm gonna find
that would be the best video game let's
see if you can get a good source but I
was reading about it today I was like I
gotta bring this up with Duncan and
we'll find out what it's about because
it's
it's just we it's a given we think that
they wrote it down and everything was
Jolly no they were hunted down they were
[ __ ] people wanted them dead yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing we're gonna
leave start your own the [ __ ] you are
yeah yeah it wasn't as simple as like
look at look at this amazing thing we
just wrote and uh now we're we're out
see ya been real no we control you we
[ __ ] control you yeah it's you yeah
cause like the myth is sort of like okay
there's the Revolutionary War ends
America is now independent and
and like you know let's let bygones be
bygones everything's fine but no I mean
there were people who are loyalists live
you know obviously they're people in the
colonies who were completely loyal to
the king I think uh
Ben Frank I think Ben Franklin's
relationship with his kid got completely
ruined because his kid was like a
loyalist and wow yeah so people like
families were getting all [ __ ] up and
like of course you know yeah because of
course the idea that you would
disconnect from mother England one of
the largest Empires ever and then also
that was what I was reading in this book
is like their fear wasn't just their
revolutionary war which
um
I think they thought they had a chance
because it's hard to operate colonies
that far away and get soldiers over
there I mean that's a tough [ __ ] war
to fight but they were worried more what
happens if we win
and now he's protecting us from all the
other countries that's what they were
worried about is like without the
protection of the throne you're just a
sitting [ __ ] duck a brand new country
easily could potentially easily be taken
over yeah and they're worried about that
such a small population yeah small
population of very very tough people
there was an article called the price
they paid this is uh 2005 Synovus
breakdown of the article it's taking
it's definitely mixed some of it was
like fictionalized a little bit but
there is a lot of Truth in it so here's
the big one five signers were captured
by the British as Traders and tortured
before they died it's true that five
signs of Declaration of Independence
were captured by the British during the
time of the Revolutionary War however
none of them died while a prisoner and
four of them were taken into Kentucky
and into custody not because they were
considered Traders due to the status as
signatories to that document but because
they were captured as prisoners of War
while engaged while actively engaged in
military operations against the British
that seems like 12 had their homes
ransacked and burned yeah but the way
they're saying that it's like
that's exactly why you're that's
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] answer if you
[ __ ] you're 100 of going after them
because they signed that yeah you're
using the excuse that you know they took
arms against the British
that they're war criminals 12 have their
homes ransacked and burned two lost
their son serving in the Revolutionary
Army another had two sons captured
nine of 56 fought and died from wounds
or hardships so is this all this stuff
true that's uh it's it's a very long
article about each breakdown it seems
like there's a little bit of [ __ ] but
it's not always the case with the
history there's always like a little
[ __ ]